that's that's that's the twitter man
twitter is a rage machine
it is twitter is a video game where you
try to figure out how to get the most
points
that's what retweets likes shares
followers
and guess what in order to get those you
have to be a mean person
that's why that's why twitter started
adding this thing where it's like are
you sure you want to call this person a
douchebag
oh really i've seen that are you still
having that i don't know did they get
rid of it i don't know
but i never called her a douchebag so
it's like i don't know if it happens to
other people like you
you'd respond to someone saying shut
your mouth you dumb you know whatever
and it would be like are you sure you
want to say this to this person what
that's awesome
it's dude twitter had an opportunity to
get rid of these things but they
they twitter is literally it's where you
go to get angry
yeah lately i have been like so i'll
retweet
like a violent protest of a guy getting
kicked in the gut and then
i'll do like two of those and then i'll
retweet like a baby smiling at the
rainbow
i'm trying it's like one out of five
joyous things i'm trying to keep it like
some level of balance i'll do like
philosophy but no one likes
people get angry when i try and be
philosophical on twitter they're like
you [ __ ]
they're like why aren't you insulting
someone over something inane don't try
and talk down to me this is not
an arbitrary and generic insult and then
they insult you because of it
but so so this is a really i got a
really funny just like quick
tidbit on on the show i can't remember
which show it was
i was talking about how conservatives
are more attractive than liberals well i
heard that
it's true so there's several studies
that back this up
and there was there's a story from the
washington post actually i think for the
sake of
avoiding you know vitriol misquoting
maybe
no people being like tim's making this
up it's like i'll just i'll just pull up
the actual
story there you go take a look oh oh
snap conservatives really are better
looking
i knew it this is just one of several
studies
and what's really funny about this is
that uh it was
a jenkinger of the young turks was
insulting me because i brought this
up somebody took a clip of me saying
that when you know when you go to the
dnc you see
overweight frumpy individuals when you
go to the rnc you see tall handsome or
busty women
and that's just uh that's that's not an
anecdote that's from me it was from a
feminist
who was explaining to me the concept of
privilege and how it breaks down between
the political parties if you go through
life as
handsome attractive with you know tall
and a deep voice and you're like ripped
people are gonna do favors for you
they're gonna be nice to you and you are
going
you're gonna be like i don't want
redistribution of my wealth i've been
able to do it on my own
this is just a general concept of
privilege and so i was actually
referencing this
they just so basically what happens is
in the context of twitter
even though you could simply google
search conservatives better looking
you would find numerous studies there's
one out of cambridge
that says people who are more attractive
tend to have conservative political
beliefs and become republican
there's also another study that says in
europe particular it's this one
referencing finland saying
they raided they had people who didn't
know the politicians of a certain
country
and asked them to write appearance and
found conservative political parties had
more attractive members
so it's cause not effect they said that
they don't know correlation or causation
but they found a correlation between you
know i would think like if you're good
looking and life is handed to you more
readily that why would you want to
change it so you tend towards more
conservation and
keeping things the status quo yeah if i
can do it on my own
funky looking and you gotta you break it
all down
right all down portland but so so so the
main issue is you get a bunch of people
like like
i'm talking about the host of the young
turks one of the biggest political
networks
he didn't even take two seconds to
google search when i said there's a
study
he tweeted at me insulting my you know
insulting me in my appearance
mocking me for you know wearing the
beauty whatever the beanie yeah and then
he said
what study and i'm like the craziest
thing is i've not said a bad word about
jan kuger i mean maybe he was critical
of him because he yelled at me at
politicon a couple years ago
nice like he just got in my face was
screaming i'm like dude but i've not
said anything
bad about him or anybody else so i'm
like why did he just decide to start
insulting me
and the crazy thing is to come on the
show man no
no it's because twitter has turned
people into
hate mongers so easy they turn him into
hate mongers so here's his opportunity
to dunk
if he didn't if he did a simple google
search you would have found that i was
not trying to denigrate anyone
i was referencing research also then but
but
this is also like what was not included
in his clip was me saying
a feminist was explaining this concept
yeah the clip was out of context it was
three clips edited together
to make one long clip it was totally out
of context of course of course and
what he could have done was simply said
i wonder if this is true instead he ends
up with you know several hundred people
all laughing and giggling amongst
themselves and high-fiving each other
about how smart they are
even though i was actually referencing a
real study right
whether you want to agree with the study
or not is it relevant there's several
studies that say the same thing
and the point i was trying to bring up
was privilege if you are a privileged
individual
of great attractiveness then you do not
want to give up what you what you've
you've you've gotten because of it and
they argued against the idea
he listened the general idea i'm the
reason i'm bringing this up is
you can get people to argue against
their own ideology
if they're dunking on you don't be angry
be the fop
so here you have a bunch of leftists
who are the ones advocating for this
concept of privilege
arguing against that very concept
because it was an opportunity to insult
me and earn points
oh wow this looks right this says to me
you know twitter is a is a tribalist
machine
that trains people to find a tribe
disregard principle and insult someone
else
you get retweets you get likes you get
followers that's why we have trump reply
guys
they have nothing of substance to add
but they are tribalists
who say trump is bad and they get
followers
then they say paypal me and they make
money amazing do you like that there's
no down vote on twitter
i don't know if that i mean actually
maybe there should be what i don't like
is that when you oh when you open
someone's tweet
you'll see like your algorithmic top
tweet
and so the left and the right see
different things oh wow people you
follow people
right that's very echo chambery exactly
so if we did
upvotes and down votes on replies then
it'd be
a much more interesting space much more
interesting and i think
it's not so cut and dry to say who would
you know dominate left or right
i think there'd be instances where the
right would upvote crazy and the left
would up vote crazy and you'd see a
little bit back and forth
it also i think could actually help the
left get more exposure to
the right which they need because the
right has exposure to the left but no
choice
not so the other way around so more
importantly i'm just like
i roll my eyes when i see you know uh
jenkins the young turks has a massive
network they get something like 50
million
uh views per month and he
is is is this the nature of his work
that
when someone calmly references
some some some research on like a
podcast that he turns it into a rage
click without research and so he's
misinforming his audience
they're all thinking that they're so
much smarter and better and the crazy
thing was how they were insulting my
appearance
i'm like but i did not directly insult
anybody i said you tend to see this the
rnc you tend to see it
at the dnc and it was actually a
feminist who made a video about this
explaining it yeah
i don't think that was in the video was
it i think it all came from because it
was out of context they didn't see the
study and what you were talking about
well i didn't show the study
yeah because it was like you know i once
read a study and you know basically what
they said was
and instead of doing a google search to
be like i wonder if that's true
they immediately just say let's drum up
hate
for money it's like the ability to make
snap judgments
about people and things is is very like
read the read the title but don't read
the article and make a comment like
that's that's
dangerous but maybe necessary for
evolution like
we have to be able to make quick snap
judgments to survive
i think i think information is traveling
so fast it didn't travel this way before
you know uh i think were we talking
about world war one or something where
it was like
it would take weeks for the messages to
come back to the us for you to even know
what was going on
crazy now there was a crazy video where
you had
gopro footage from a tank and from the
people shooting at the tank
yeah interesting stories and some news
organization put the clips together and
they're like for the first time you have
video footage from both sides of an
active conflict good
so this is coming in in really really
quickly and so what ends up happening is
back in the day what did you have to
read you didn't have twitter
you had a pamphlet that came and has
three things to say on it you're going
to read all of it because ain't nothing
else to read
now i i got 5 000 tweets every minute
who
what's the firehouse on twitter is
ridiculous so you're just like
flipping through like oh i can only read
a few things and people
are just being it's information overload
so what's crazy is
there's uh i love how there's like this
idea of the grifter
when i was talking to a friend of mine
and he was like bro you just make you
know angry videos insulting democrats
because it's your business model you
know what you're doing and i'm like
i know what i'm doing and that i have an
opinion and i was like and you
posting your complaints on social media
is literally the same thing
the only difference is i do it as a job
and you do it endlessly all day for
posting memes i guess i don't know also
speaking on video is very different it
takes a certain level of confidence
and it changes you to communicate via
video i mean that's a powerful medium
because i
just i just mean like one of the things
that's happening right now is that
there's no way i could know everything
so of course i get things wrong all the
time
i'm a dude who's giving his opinion on
on main on major news
trying to use certified sources and do
my best to fact check and
there are people who are like tim's
misinforming people and i'm like and so
is
the young turks and so is stephen
crowder and so is so his sticks
everybody is getting something wrong
everybody is doing this it's a very very
different ecosystem now you can argue
it's bad
maybe it really is i don't know what the
solution is it seems necessary whatever
it is
we're all trying to assert like actually
this is true because of this reason
and then someone's saying no tim's wrong
and here's why yeah it's like trying to
be right
is less important than trying to be
honest yeah
trying to win i think trying to win for
your tribe that's something that makes
me nervous about trump's
because he talks about winning and it
makes me like really nervous i don't
like it
i don't like i don't like the idea of of
tribes and i don't like
or i i don't care about tribes i don't
like the i don't want to be in anyone's
tribe i wanna i'm gonna go build my own
shack in the middle of the woods
down you know with a little river and a
dog you leave me alone you know i'm
gonna do my thing you do yours very very
very libertine just let me just leave me
alone is the dog in your tribe
yes yes that's his entire tribe he wants
that's what i've talked about i'm i'm
very left libertarian in the sense that
i'm all about having a hippie farm
we have our own little farm we have a
small group of people we share we get
along
everything's great leave us alone it
doesn't work in a grand scale
life libertarianism you know with big
cities but that's what that's what i'm
do you leave me alone
and we're going to share you know our
fruits and veggies and you know we just
got we got a bunch of jalapenos that
just came from the garden
oh i shouted out all those new peppers
we got ghost peppers
fyi delicious for the win those are
amazing
spices they're like they smell like
green pepper but i think they're red
i have no idea they're they're spicy and
so spicy and they make new peppers out
of like
ghost peppers so like a lot of these
really hot peppers or ghost pepper uh
amalgams you know they what do they call
it when they blend hybrid yeah hybrids
yeah
i have no idea what i was talking about
all peppers emotions and being a
youtuber like having the burden of
trying to communicate
no no just like just just how people uh
everyone thinks they're right and
everyone else is wrong and the challenge
now is that
even with people like me where i produce
content
i'm just one perspective and so that's
why i'm often telling people you got to
watch other shows too
because otherwise i'm probably missing a
big piece of the picture i'm just one
person
this is where the left comes up short
because they're telling you brian
stelter and this guy in that video we
watched earlier stop watching fox news
dude screw you watch every single news
source
so that you can form your own opinion
and i'm constantly listening to people
and i'm trying to find what little bit
of truth they have to tell me
because 90 of it is their opinion and
there's a little bit of truth in there
and i'll take it and i'll use it
you know why i really want people to
watch every news source
because if you have somebody who only
watches fox news and then they watch cnn
and then you have somebody who only
watches cnn and they watch fox news
both of them are going to go cnn is
lying
oh good point yeah cnn is notoriously
bad journalism
oh it's it's yes my favorite was when
don lemon was at talking to a panel and
he goes
a lot of people on the internet are
talking about you know black holes and i
know it's
preposterous but you know mary is it
preposterous
is the missing malaysian airplane right
oh did it fell into a black hole yeah
yeah and then the woman goes
oh you know rigory or even a small black
hole would swallow the whole universe
it just got worse you know what man and
then i was watching fox and friends
one morning and they had a priest on to
talk about how evolution wasn't real
right right right fox news but uh but
i'll tell you what
prime time i think tucker carlson does a
really really really good job yeah he's
carrying the torch man yeah he is i'm
impressed
and did you see when jon stewart just
basically brow beat him
back in the day it was when tucker had a
great reckoning he used to wear a bow
tie and it was uh crossfire
yeah yeah they had jon stewart on the
show and jon stewart made a mockery out
of tucker and tucker just took it he
just listened to him because he had a
lot of
he had a lot of like respect for john
and and he it changed his
mind and he became a better journalist
after that wow yeah tucker has
uh changed a lot for the better for sure
like he had a segment i think last year
where he was anti-pot legalization
and it felt forced i was like you don't
really believe this like we should
definitely legalize pot and get these
non-violent offenders out of jail
i'm sure i wonder where he's at today on
that because if trump came out right now
and said
we're doing an executive order
non-violent defenders will be reviewed
pardoned released full commute you know
sentence commuted and
expunged it's landslides yeah easily yes
but you know biden's talking about that
oh good for him yep yep isn't it credit
where credit's due like i don't think
i'm a good point kyle harrison threw a
bunch of people in jail for i know
and laughed about it yeah yeah but to be
fair what did pence do what did pence do
right
not much it's true and he was in a
smaller state than commonwealth
oh what did he do he was the he was the
governor of indiana right yeah
so he so the reason i bring him up is
because to be completely honest
i should be able to be like actually
hear things that but i don't know
anything about pence
i wonder if that's why donald trump
picked him because he's a kind of a
silence indian or something yep
so he's been criticized for his stance
on like homosexuality and stuff like
that that's the most that i know
and i know kamala has been has been
dragged heavily but that
it is it is it is fair to say look um
there was a post someone made about joe
biden wanting to legalize pot and
and uh release not non-violent offenders
and he said it for a while
and i'm like that's a great thing that
is that is absolutely a good thing yeah
the only problem is i just don't think
he's a real candidate
like he joe biden could come out and say
everything that trump is saying and i'd
still say
bro you're a flashlight with dying
batteries that's a good analogy that's
joe rogan's yeah yeah it was brilliant
and so i actually was thinking about it
and the way i described it was
if i had to go into a dark cave and have
my choice between a flashlight with
dying batteries and a torch that could
burn me i gotta take the torch man
the torch is gonna be consistent it's
gonna work
it's gonna be hot it's gonna be
dangerous but i know it will
keep the light going yeah the light's
the most important thing yeah
and and the flashlights better tech it's
it's you know
it just you need the batteries man it
was not going to work
what if you could have a dying
flashlight or a gorilla with the
headlight strapped to its forehead i'm
seeing the comparison yeah
um i man i follow that gorilla i'm gonna
go with the girl he's the girl of my
friend
well it's up to you he fights for you
he's gonna like
kill me i've never been that close to a
gorilla all right well hopefully we can
rip you in half hopefully we're friends
yes we've run up together and we're on
an adventure together and he's leading
the way he has your best interests in
mind oh excellent that he'll fight off
the the morlocks and the
dude homie yeah could use that
strength thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you